[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette dernière édition de la semaine de
votre journal nous sommes le 13 octobre
voici les titres de votre journal
quotidien d'actualité locale et long
cours ville pilote en france dans le
domaine célèbre une décennie de
numérique depuis dix ans les équipes
pédagogiques utilisent les outils
numériques la fête de la science à
l'observatoire de saint quentin en
yvelines on reçoit des enfants pour
évoquer les grandes thématiques de la
recherche et susciter pourquoi pas des
vocations et puis à sartrouville le
théâtre vient de fêter ses cinquante
bougies un demi-siècle après il reste le
seul centre dramatique national de la
grande couronne parisienne à l'actualité
du jour en économie c'est la première
édition du sky business day permettre
aux tpe et aux pme de rencontrer les
grands comptes ce lors d'un rendez vous
c'est le but de cette opération cela se
déroulait aujourd'hui au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'événement
organisé par l'agglomération est plutôt
un succès 400 entreprises présentes et
plus de 3000 rendez vous ecoutez jean
michel fourgous c'est le vice-président
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines en charge de cette question de
l'économie et c'est au micro de
haussmann 22 rebelles
s'ils voulaient augmenter la croissance
des entreprises il vous simplement
augmenter leurs échanges donc dé
multiplier les échanges donc c'est le
but de cette journée aujourd'hui ou
avec un partenaire spécialisé on a donc
programmé 3600 rendez vous ce qui est
exceptionnel donc des rendus ou
prospects comme on dit dans l'entreprise
qui va permettre à des petits et des
gros seins des pme et des grands groupes
d'échangés et de plus travailler
ensemble comme enseigner à l'école avec
les outils numériques c'était le thème
de ce séminaire qui s'est tenu hier
après-midi à elles ont cours depuis 10
ans cette ville saint-quentinoise
introduit le numérique dans ces
établissements avec et des tablettes des
tableaux numériques ou encore et des
robots une évolution pas toujours facile
à appréhender pour les enseignants qui
doivent constamment se forme et camille
lambert et mélanie poquet pour ce sujet
ces enseignants ne sont pas en train de
jouer s'ils manipulent des briques de
construction c'est pour penser une
nouvelle façon d'enseigner dans leur
salle de classe avec le numérique un
espace idéal ce serait un espace mille
enseignants se sent bien on l'élève se
sent bien il a envie d'apprendre
c'est aussi un espace qui propose
différentes activités
permet une circulation d'eau qui permet
des temps et individuelles au calme qui
permet des temps de travail en commun
entre élèves ou avec l'enseignant
s'adapter aux élèves faire une pédagogie
de projet alors même si on ne répète
depuis des années et une impulsion pour
que nos résultats s'améliorent et faire
que nos élèves apprennent mieux
apprennent avec du plaisir dans les
yvelines 38% des classes sont équipées
d'un tableau vidéo projecteur numérique
à elancourt les écoles élémentaires sont
passés à l'ère numérique depuis dix ans
c'est bien d'avoir un écosystème une
infrastructure en pédagogie numérique l
encours et qu'ils soient de haute
qualité mais bien entendu le prof
restent au centre pédagogique donc il
faut régulièrement échanger les
expériences
renforcer la formation continue des
profs parce que ça évolue très vite et
ça c'est très créatif saran et prof très
créatif 200 enseignants d'elancourt de
la verrière et de maurepas ont participé
à ce séminaire en france le plan
numérique est déployée depuis la rentrée
2015 1800 écoles ont intégré cette année
et du éducation toujours l'académie de
versailles a célébré pendant deux jours
les 30 ans de l'instauration du
baccalauréat professionnel le premier
diplôme de formation en alternance école
entreprise pour fêter cet anniversaire
les étudiants ont investi le palais des
congrès de versailles mercredi et jeudi
lors d'un forum une vingtaine de stands
tenus par les élèves et leurs
professeurs étaient installés pour
promouvoir les différentes filières
présentes dans l'académie comme la
coiffure la vente ou encore les muscles
j'ai beaucoup entendu de mal sur le bac
professionnel mais j'ai toujours fait la
part des choses pour moi j'avais envie
d'être un professionnel donc j'ai
toujours défendues professionnels et
pour moi après chacun son avis mais on
va que professionnel on peut plus
attendre le monde du travail alors qu'en
bac général c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué je pense que l'image des bacs
pro a bien évolué du côté de des lycées
du côté des entreprises mais passer du
côté du public et des familles il faut
que les familles sachent que faire un
bac professionnel
c'est une formation de très grande
qualité qui permet l'emploi et qui
permet la poursuite d'études il faut en
faire la promotion c'est un très très
bel objet propos recueillis par michael
et demi d'euros nous parlions du
numérique à l'école il ya quelques
instants et bien un jardin et
poulaillers ont aussi trouvé leur place
au sein des établissements l'objectif
est bien évidemment est d'éduquer les
enfants aux enjeux environnementaux est
due au développement durable également
sur le département des yvelines la
direction académique des services de
l'éducation nationale soutient cette
ambition elle a labellisé certains
établissements scolaires ceux qui sont
les plus en avance sur ce sujet le
reportage de patrick jacques de dixmude
d'abord l'anguille et de nicolas
kirillovitch
une poule un potager des outils ce n'est
pas encore l'école à la ferme et on s'y
croirait presque pour les élèves de
l'école primaire les petits près
d'elancourt en plus des habituels
mathématiques français histoire
l'environnement s'est fait une place au
sein de l'enseignement à prendre le
cycle de l'oeuf et favoriser la ponte
ont d'ailleurs un intérêt pour tous on
les récolte et après on les ramène chez
nous par élève il ya une seule personne
qui ramène à neuf après il y en a
d'autres qui vont enfin le long débat
peut être la poule est va pondre dans
que dzeko on va on prend un café en leur
âme une chine promouvoir l'éducation au
développement durable et initier les
plus jeunes aux problématiques
écologiques sont devenus depuis des
années des priorités pour l'éducation
nationale dans les yvelines une
vingtaine d'écoles viennent de recevoir
un label spécial pour les récompenser
dans leurs démarches c'était intéressant
c'est aussi de développer une démarche
c'est d'engager
ces enfants qui sont les citoyens de
demain de s'approprier des réflexions
deux sociétés c'est à dire que
sur sur le tri des déchets sur le libre
ensemble sur la consommation
ressources changement climatique ou
encore alimentation les thèmes abordés
avec les écoliers sont variés et
complète l'apprentissage des matières
historique jeux précités montaigne par
exemple c'est à dire faire avoir une
tête bien faite plutôt qu'une tête bien
pleine c'est à dire développer d'abord
des méthodes des méthodes de travail
mais des méthodes de vide et après bien
entendu basé tout ça sur le cercle vert
des connaissances ce qu'on voit
reprendre cyr l'école pour la nouvelle
année scolaire l'éducation nationale et
espère labellisé une trentaine de
nouveaux établissements dans les
yvelines
c'est un événement national la fête de
la science se poursuit jusqu'au 16
octobre à cette occasion lové est-ce qu
l'observatoire de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines qui dépend de
l'université ouvre ses portes au grand
public et puis également aux écoles ce
matin ce sont des élèves de rambouillet
qui ont participé à différents ateliers
le grand public sera lui donc accueilli
la journée de dimanche et nous avons
suivi quelques animations avec les
élèves travaillent et du verre en fusion
une première pour ces élèves de l'école
darbo ville de rambouillet sous la
direction de vincent il découvre le
métier de souffleur de verre en
laboratoire une expérience proposée par
l'observatoire de versailles saint
quentin dans le cadre de la fête de la
science
qu'on le club est pas sa faune et du
coup ça tombe un peu monsieur
le milieu des grosses
appris après sa grande soeur segment b
j'essayais de quartiers difficiles mais
ça brûle et enfin c'était aussi mon
savoir
cette semaine mauvaise qui accueille
près de 800 élèves dans ses locaux un
événement pour apprendre la science
autrement la science c'est quand même
assez abstrait et là par quelques petits
ateliers on arrive un petit peu plus
précisément à dire un scientifique ça
fait ça et ça sert à quoi ça sert à des
choses quand même très précises parfois
ça suscite des vocations avec le latmos
les enfants découvrent aussi
l'atmosphère de quoi est elle constituée
comment l'analyser c'est l'objet de
cette expérience les jeunes apprennent
l'utilisation des ballons au service de
la science comme on est un laboratoire
qui a un long passé de l'exploration
spatiale avec des fusées des ballons on
essaie de leur expliquer pidement
l'intérêt et la physique qui a autour
des ballons l'intérêt pour l'atmosphère
pour la prévision météo que donc on est
bien au courant des informations qu'on a
tous les jours chaque enfant a pu écrire
sur une carte postale accroché à un
ballon gonflé d'hélium ils ont été
ensuite libérés dans le ciel certains
arriveront peut-être en allemagne où
jusqu'en suède dimanche 16 octobre le vs
qu sera ouvert au public les grands
curieux pourront eux aussi tester ces
ateliers
d'un mois de politique à présent avec le
premier débat entre les candidats de la
droite et du centre ce sera ce jeudi
soir sur tf1 à 21h alors que le duel
juppé sarkozy domine la campagne les
outsideurs se prépare aussi à
l'affrontement nouvelle épreuve après
les meetings et vous le voyez d'ailleurs
quasiment tous les candidats se sont
rendus dans le département des yvelines
ces derniers mois et on notera aussi
qu'un yvelinois participent à cette
primaire c'est jean frédéric poisson le
député de la 10e circonscription
président du parti chrétien démocrate il
est pour l'instant crédité de 2%
d'intentions de vote dans les sondages
et puisque l'on parle politique prochain
numéro du 7-8 politique sur notre
antenne ce sera ce vendredi 14 octobre
dès 20h nicolas kirillovitch s'est rendu
au parlement européen pour en construire
constance legris eurodéputés les
républicains qui sera question de
l'union bien sûr mais aussi de la crise
des migrants écouter cet extrait c'est
un sujet aussi qui concerne le local
puisque également dans les yvelines une
des manifestations récemment pour
dénoncer l'arrivée future de migrants on
parle de 800 400 nouveaux migrants
plutôt saffré 800 au total sur une
population de plus d'un million de
personnes est ce que vous vous
intéressez aussi à ces inquiétudes
locales est ce que vous pencher dessus
en tant qu'eurodéputé francilienne
j'entends les inquiétudes des
populations
parce qu'elles sont souvent exprimé
assez fortement comment ne pas les
entendre et puis je comprend également
les interrogations des élus locaux des
mères qui voudraient pouvoir être
entendu être accompagnée le cas échéant
être consultés
en amont je pense qu'il faut faire
preuve de considération et d'attention
vis-à-vis de ce que peuvent exprimer des
élus locaux et les maires et qu'il ne
faut pas plaquer sur des communes d
[Musique]
faculté d'accueil rendez-vous donc
vendredi 14 octobre dès 20h sur notre
antenne pour ce nouveau 7,8 politique
nous refermons ce journal en attendant
avec et de la culture le théâtre de
sartrouville a officiellement 50 ans
cette année et il accueille encore
trente mille spectateurs chaque saison
c'était le cas l'année dernière le
reportage de maxime le même pour le
conseil départemental des yvelines dans
les années 60 le tout jeune patrice
chéreau pose les bases de ce qui
deviendra le théâtre de sartrouville
durant trois saisons il met en scène des
spectacles audacieux destiné à un public
de banlieue à l'époque c'est vrai que
entre paris et la banlieue il y avait
vraiment une césure une coupure qui n'a
plus lieu d'être
et donc à l'évidence c'est parce qu'il
ya eu des pionniers des gens qui avaient
le militantisme chevillée au corps et la
rencontre avec des politiques de toutes
sensibilité d'ailleurs qu' il ya pu y
avoir ce théâtre ici à sartrouville
aujourd'hui le théâtre est labellisée
centre dramatique national
il accueille trente mille spectateurs
par an j'aime bien là la variété des
spectacles parce qu'on peut avoir du
théâtre de la danse de la musique de la
magie du cirque on met à peu près cinq
minutes pour ne se rendre aux terres
dont le soir le spectacle se termine à
11 heures et à 11h15 on est chez nous
c'est quand même très très commode
depuis 1997 le conseil départemental
subventionne l'établissement dans le
cadre d'odyssée en yvelines un festival
qui permettent au jeune public de
découvrir sur tout le territoire des
créations originales
à l'occasion des 50 ans du théâtre de
sartrouville le département a rappelé
son engagement aux côtés de la culture
et de ses lieux de diffusion ce sont des
lieux de vie ce sont des lieux qui sont
ouverts aux actions culturelles pas
uniquement des lieux de diffusion des
lieux d'attractivité et d'accompagnement
sur la vie du quotidien pour des pour
l'intergénérationnel ce important en
2016 le département a dédié près de 6
millions d'euros au patrimoine et à la
culture
merci de nous avoir suivis prochain
prochain journal en direct à 18h à lundi
en attendant pour ce week end et
vendredi vous avez rendez vous avec
nicolas kirillovitch pour le 7 8 l hebdo
à très bientôt
[Musique]